- [Mark] Okay, Lindsay, where
are you from originally?
Where did you grow up?
- I grew up in Lakewood, California.
I mean I grew up all
around America, actually,
the United States, but I was
based in Lakewood, California.
I was kind of well off,
I guess you could say
middle class, growing up.
- [Mark] Kind of like a
suburb of Long Beach, right?
- Yeah, it's like the
abuse started when I was
in my late teens.
- [Mark] What happened?
- When I was about 15, my
mom, she used to date like,
people that played, like sports stars.
And then out of nowhere she
started dating this loser.
I mean, he seemed to have it all together,
but come to find out, you know,
he was just this guy
taking advantage of her.
And when he thought he
was going to lose that,
he got very violent with us.
And then when I came out, as a woman,
as wanting to be a woman,
and I mean maybe being gay,
that it was just the perfect
excuse to throw me out.
At times, a lot when I was
18, I had nowhere to go.
I find this deluded shape and
memories, almost as if I'm
aching out for a premonition
or vision to be instilled in me
at every moment of the
good times, you know.
When I was in Hollywood
making it as a model,
and a lot of things actually,
but there's this psychotic,
bent shape that it's almost
as if it would have to
catch my peripherals
because it would be the
most disrepectful thing
that I don't think, right now I would cry
but usually I get angry, to look at people
and recognize how much they
have taken advantage of me
at times I tried to have
compassion for the people
I ran into when I was homeless
and stirred into prostitution.
With the idea that it was
a normal thing, you know,
I had witnessed drive-bys
and stuff as a kid.
I mean it's LA, that's normal
for us in southern California.
But I had never witnessed
prostitution and it's like
you almost agree to having a
way of belittling yourself.
'Cause human trafficking's not a joke
and there's areas we
know to stay away from,
like Figaro Boulevard, and
those people have no compassion,
and they're so inhumane,
and people like that,
they come from all around.
I have a belief spiritually though.
- [Mark] So tell me about your childhood.
- Well when I was growing
up, this woman tried.
growing up actually, I was gifted.
I was a genius.
My school, we got to meet George Bush,
because we were geniuses, and
we were on the news and stuff.
My sister, she's going
to school to be a lawyer.
My brother, he's amazing too, but I've got
the middle child syndrome.
- [Mark] Was there
anything in your childhood
that may have set you on this course,
of wanting to be a woman?
- [Lindsay] No, it was really
recognizing an agreeance
to keeping myself
obedient, no, disciplined,
when having nowhere to go.
It's like I agreed to this
humbleness and gratefulness,
because I have a lot of respect for people
in the way I act, but in
reality, growing up now I see,
that people are fucking sick.
When I went to Hollywood, I became a model
and I did some adult
stuff because I wanted to.
I used to make a good amount of money,
I would cut off $9
thousand here and there.
- [Mark] Doing what?
- [Lindsay] $9 thousand
for about a day's work.
At times I would make--
- [Mark] As what?
- As a model, I mean
honestly I really did.
It's like I have this
awareness and keenness really,
I got the it factor, I know that.
- [Mark] When you say
model, what kind of model?
- I started off modeling
clothes and also I did gender,
what is it called?
I used to say it and it
isn't really a big deal,
but nowadays I'm always
watching what I say.
Gender fluid modeling, it
was edgy and avant-garde
and it was a huge part
of me, but then I got
into adult modeling and somebody
did try to ruin me with it,
but it didn't work.
Then I started to fall off
with running into the people
that are okay with the
fact that I was raped,
'cause they lived in the area.
I didn't know that they were homeless,
and when they were they
would just live with me.
They would stay at my house all the time.
Running into the guy
that raped me eventually,
I got kidnapped, well
he used force to move me
and keep me there, and
raped, and he urinated on me,
he gave me two black eyes,
welts all over my head,
lots of blood.
I had nothing to wear and
the miracle I was staring at
the clothes, there was a
toddler's clothes right there.
In my heart, I had all
these dreams of what it
could have been, like
maybe a family member
who gave me something.
I put 'em on, and he was
actually trying to get somebody
to get there that day to have me killed.
Two youngsters, I remember the
vision of them driving away,
I just knew it was them.
I called my cousin, 'cause he
didn't know I had my phone,
and I'm like, "where did
this phone come from?"
With everything that's going
on, it seemed like a miracle.
It was just there, and I
called my cousin, Kira,
and she was racing to get
me, but he broke the phone
before I could tell her
exactly where I was.
He repeatedly raped me,
he had people watching,
keeping me there, before he could kill me.
They couldn't find us so he thought
that having a group take
me to where I could get
brought to the place of my death.
I ran, he hit me with a big
rock, I just kept running.
I went to Santa Monica Rape Center,
I have his name, I have everything.
Detective Brown that works with
the Los Angeles County Sheriff's,
and all of the detectives,
they at first didn't want to see me.
They looked at me as somebody
with pee all over themselves,
that was thrown on me,
blood, face all messed up,
as something that was normal.
It's like I could almost hear what they
would be saying in their head.
I knew that it was because
they had the assumption,
"It's just another one
of these prostitutes."
I started to recognize from everything
I was catching around me,
almost to say right now, I'm
not being polite or anything,
it would have to be
peripherals or something.
Because staring at them, I
heard what they were saying.
They were saying prostitute and stuff.
I knew that they couldn't
look me in the eye
to say it.
- [Mark] So Lindsay--
- I had to throw water in the
peoples' face at Fatburger
'cause they wouldn't call 911,
I said, "He's trying to kill me,"
I was hiding under the
seat, and they said,
"We don't call the cops."
The indifference in LA, it's fucking sick.
A homeless person going
crazy with no clothes,
somebody with nothing to eat even,
who doesn't have any way
of taking care of themself,
or even a woman who just got raped,
no one cares, no one would
call the cops for you.
That's just reality.
90% of these people are so shit-fucked,
they're lost if they think they're going
to find a place called Heaven.
If this shit keeps going
on, we're going to be living
in a horrible place here in LA.
But then I see how many women think
that the fact of getting
raped and not agreeing to sex
is something that they can just give into.
I know that breed is dying.
I've been in and out
of jail as prostitutes,
but at the same time I
recently was in a sicker place,
just looking around and agreeing to see
what my ears were catching,
'cause I run a lot
since I haven't been driving.
I need a car really bad,
'cause walking around,
this people are fucking sick, everywhere.
- [Mark] Lindsay, where
do you stay at night?
- I stay in hotels, but
there's these people
that have my card right now
and they're just the same
thing, the same abuse,
they're keeping my money from me.
I have thousands of
dollars, at least, right now
to spend, and they're
telling me things like,
"unless you agree,"
and they know I'm a victim
of rape and things like that,
"to saying that you're mental."
They didn't say to agree to that.
It's a mental health crisis, these people
have mental problems themselves
and they're telling me.
- [Mark] Lindsay, have you been
in a mental health facility?
- I've been in a mental health facility
to my agreeance, a few times.
Three times very recently,
I've been forced to go
because these people
are stealing my money,
and they're acting like it's a
joke to laugh about everyday.
Her name is Natalie.
I'm running out, but not all the way,
'cause I have something saved up.
If I could just keep my mind together
before I have another anxiety attack.
Then I start walking around nicer areas,
bouncing around from hotel to hotel,
then I could probably get it together
and get everything I need
just to get it all set up.
It seems like every day is
just a new day to survive.
- [Mark] Are there medications that--
- I don't even know what I'm running from.
I don't take medications.
I'm not gravely disabled.
I have almost an obsessive
personality disorder,
obsessive compulsions, I've seen that.
My personality disorder
is really just a PTSD,
and the anxiety I keep to
myself but then I get empty.
The only thing I'm really scared of
is how many people will
take advantage of me
if I'm in an area like this.
Homeless people are everywhere,
and if you think that
the one that are on drugs
and steal everything aren't more prone
to rape you, then you're wrong.
- [Mark] Lindsay, do
you use any of the drugs
that are on the street?
- Honestly I like
hallucinogenics and things
that have sort of a flower
child tryptamine effect.
I used something yesterday
and it didn't feel
like being high, it felt like being empty.
Squared away to where I felt it,
it didn't have anything to it.
If they think that's
amphetamine, it's not.
I'm lucky though, because
a lot of my friends
have been dying, my friends that do drugs,
off of the fentanyl shit.
- [Mark] Do you have family?
- I have a sister who's in law school,
and she lives really far
away but she's really
mad at me because I got a
little too high last time.
We were getting high together
but it's almost as if
my entire family, at
times my immediate family,
as in my brother, not my brother,
my sister, my mom, my other
sister, my cousin, my uncle,
my aunts, they have this
idea that they can just
part from me in my times of need and
that I'll have some distance and dwelling
and I'll be A-okay, even when
I'm reaching out to them.
I know not to, because
honestly I just feel
like they're jealous.
They don't really agree
with my personality,
I know it's 'cause I'm a homosexual too.
But I'm a woman in my heart.
- [Mark] So, have you been
beaten up on the street?
- Last time I got beat up on the street,
which time was that?
I got hit with a blunt object
and attacked by this man
who was trying to grope me, yes.
It was in Lakewood, California, I believe.
I had gotten hit a few times that day
and I was hanging out with
a distant cousin of mine.
She's distant 'cause we don't
really know her that well.
I was hanging out with her
and she got with this guy
that I used to know
when I was a prostitute,
who was homeless.
Walking back and forth, I got
attacked a bunch of times.
There was a lot of blood, I have a scar.
It was like no one really cared
except for one of my lovers.
- [Mark] Lindsay, thank you
so much for talking to me.
- But I also had dreams
of becoming an actor.
I wrote amazing lyrics and
I've actually had people
use them.
I'm going to become a musician.
I'm gonna do networking for casting and
be an agent for models and in the adult
entertainment industry
and in entertainment,
commercials, models, acting.
So they don't get played.
Also I hope I get to meet a
lot of hot, amazing people
like you.
- [Mark] (chuckles) All right
Lindsay, thank you so much.
- [Lindsay] Do I get paid for this?
- [Mark] You do.
- [Lindsay] Tight!